Xbox series S price and launch date
revealed breath of the wild prequel
announced but sadly we're going to have
to wait sometime for news on the sequel
I'm Lucy and these are the biggest
gaming news stories for Tuesday
September
[Music]
8th officially the worst kept secret in
gaming but Microsoft has now officially
announced the Xbox series s the cheaper
alternative to the upcoming series X it
is the smallest Xbox ever and costs
$299 that's
£250 and it's out on November 10th it
has a minimalist design and no disc
drive and has sparked 1,000 memes
already that price for nextg console is
wild we're still waiting for the price
and date for the more powerful series X
they're not confirmed yet but there is a
report from Windows Central that claims
that November 10th will be the launch of
the series X as well but it will have a
$499 price tag we can't say if that
report is accurate just yet but they did
correctly leak the series s for what
it's worth all right Sony it's
your and speaking of November God is
that going to be one hell of a busy
month because we'll also have hyru
Warriors age of Calamity now it's
another Dynasty Warrior Style muso game
and it's set 100 years before the events
of breath of the wild it's not 100%
combat game though it will have
traditional puzzles too using the Chica
slate L and Zelda are playable once
again but you can also play as the four
Champions the key art also shows a small
Guardian so that might be a playable
character too the game's coming out on
November
20th that's not all the Zelda news for
today but this one is more of a please
manage your expectations story on top of
today's age of Calamity announcement
Zelda producer AG auma asked fans to
wait a bit longer for breath of the wild
2 news regarding the sequel in order to
make the vast world you enjoyed explore
exporing in the original game even more
impressive the team is working hard on
its development so you'll have to wait a
bit longer before we can provide more
updates we haven't seen any more of the
game since the 2019 reveal trailer with
Link and Zelda exploring a cave where
dry Ganon is hanging out what would you
like to see from a breath of the wild
sequel are you going to get the series s
or are you going to hold out for the
series X let me know in the comments
below come find me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games and I think I'm going
to wait for the series X although you
really can't sniff at that $300 price
tag I'll see you next
[Music]
time